as a Swedish man I am gifted with many
great kids
blonde beautiful hair awkward awkward
transitioning beer
good cutting skills but most of all
their skills to play video games and
skiing especially games about skiing in
video games
that's my fifth gift this game is like
skate med skiing so we need to go at the
end of the mountain over this music man
oh I'm shaking my crotch back and forth
but you can't see it here break out
gonna ski the [ __ ] out of this place
nailed it let's go this way
yes Swedish powers this is how it's done
I hope I meet a bear so I can [ __ ] him
fight him fight him jump oh god that's a
rock uhh
ah [ __ ] the [ __ ] was that we're fine
we're fine Jesus saved us from that one
thank you Jesus
okay all right here we go what the [ __ ]
is that oh my god what the [ __ ] is this
oh you reset from a point where you
didn't suck so much dick okay got it
okay slow down [ __ ] you [ __ ] get
telling me how to live my left Oh got a
tree ah oh [ __ ] my facial expression
just like a [ __ ] up mom oh god how do
I turn [ __ ] trees everywhere go back and
yeah
Oh God not the rocks my biggest enemy Oh
Dutch that [ __ ] I'm at the rocks [ __ ] I
became their ash look at this what
[ __ ] up ha ha
hep did you get a cricketer quicker than
a mini acting the mall card is just
gotta go fast oh [ __ ] it's going fast
panicking panicking ah nail that oh god
I'm in the [ __ ] ski resort what the
[ __ ] am I doing here hey I'm at the bar
what's up I'll have a martini please
faster faster I'm a car damn it Brum
Brum [ __ ] can you imagine driving on
the road and you just see some [ __ ]
on skis what is that a truck go in the
truck I'm not like that where my body go
uh oh god what am i doing are you okay
there buddy
uh bro hey hey you need to start skiing
real soon we're gonna be in trouble man
come on do something wake up I think
he's sleeping
I think he's narcoleptic we're gonna oh
this is our home
Marcia Marcia I'm home [ __ ] Josh [ __ ]
[ __ ] with god damn it oh my god oh god
oh god this is bad oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
fine
ah oh yes oh we're fine we're fine we're
fine we're totally fine
I never end oh god I'm fine oh [ __ ] this
is my new chance
finally finally gonna do some epic
skiing
I hope the babes are watching okay here
we go
girls ready for this y'all ready for
that [ __ ] y'all ready for this
aah Oh what backflip now
Wow oh my god that's so cool and now
we're laughs oh okay and now we go to
space apparently rotation is 68 or p.m.
okay get ready to match our spin with
the retro thrusters
oh don't [ __ ] this up man huh
more another God Oh God God God oh yeah
that was awesome
Oh God hey LM sorry go in everyone wait
a minute you guys aren't people what the
[ __ ] is going on kidding me this makes
me actually want to go skiing this game
I don't explain it alright let's ride
the lip hey hey hey hey hey
get the lip get the lip where you going
you piece of trash okay here it comes
it's always so tricky huh what was that
okay fine you know what we don't need a
lift to ski we just need okay we go
again go lift Oh God we're going so fast
oh oh okay oh I think that's an all the
fun we're gonna have for now really
enjoy this game it's really cool I hope
you enjoyed this episode if you did give
it a thumbs up I really enjoy this game
really cool and I would love to do more
so if you wanted to see more let me know
in the comments and I'll see you bros in
the next one
it's always stay awesome press now let's
rock oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
damnit